I'm not just fooling up hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to Spooky's House of jump-scares now I
was oh I was oh okay
ah be right back moving to vote him okay
I forgot that I was supposed to go into
the future and figure out what I was
supposed to do before I got back okay so
those doors are better it's like me Oh
God
oh wow oh [ __ ] ah that was not fun who
hot damn okay so where does this lead is
this new seems like it might be new okay
so this is the end of this hallway maybe
if I back up walk backwards maybe
they'll give me some where nope that
didn't do nothing
oh no this is commit damn it god damn it
okay that didn't help okay so this leads
down this way what is that this broken
okay so it's like a slightly symmetrical
layout with two broken sides but this
one does have this room in here so maybe
there's something in this room
okay so this is the connecting hallway
so that just flips back and forth
between the two locales that's broken as
well
the endless hallway is kind of in the
middle yeah this is the endless hallways
so maybe there's a way to go through
this that I'm not understanding so if I
made no progress wait a minute
oh hi Wow okay found it
hello again everybody alright ah hi what
are you doing here alrighty then do you
have anything for me to progress through
the endless hallway because that's
what's really biting my bottom now ah
nope nope nope so is it really nothing
here oh there we go
man whoo oh no oh yeah where's like oh
good
ah that's like me well I got a walk
quietly back up these stairs don't mind
me I'm just floating like a butterfly
yeah okay so I got what I needed
apparently I've got the isolation key
which I remember I think it's in the
basement dad I'm not a hundred percent
sure on that one whoo that was not that
was not fun I didn't even know what was
chasing me but I didn't like it and I
haven't I have a funny feeling I'm gonna
have to go down there again oh hello
baby how are you doing okay so now I'm
gonna go save like a Baus I know this is
supposed to be like a safe space and
make you feel good about life but I have
a funny feeling they're gonna take away
that particular feeling of safety at any
juncture but okay I'm pretty sure I'm
fairly certain that down in the basement
there's something sinister looking for
me and I will find it
and I will bring him to justice this
hospital like I can't imagine that there
were good things happening in this
hospital whole lot of bad stuff okay so
the goop is still there and if I recall
was it in this section
no the break room and don't ask me why
the break room is in the basement like
that that's just really creepy okay so I
must mount on the opposite side because
there were there were a bunch of morgue
doors but if I recalled the very odd
house it I'm pretty sure at the very end
of the hallway there was an isolation
room hey Bubba Bubba Bubba hey Bubba how
you doing are you so nice alright good
to hear I guess have a nice day
patrolling the hallways keeping us safe
like you should
hope I don't see sandbag man okay here
we go
I have a funny feeling that's not gonna
be very fun for me oh oh no oh boy oh
boy oh boy it wasn't me I swear it
wasn't it may have been my body in my
hands but I know it wasn't me oh that's
comforting
so who did you murder who'd you do that
to huh Oh broken good I didn't want to
go in there anyway what's the point of
even having the doors if they're all
gonna be broken like that I don't know
something sinister is down here with us
broken broken hello I found out how to
stop them you can you see they're in my
head and can control me for a time but
if I keep using the radiology machine to
dose my head with radiation then they go
away for a while oh is that all
oh just a blaster radiation through my
skull ain't gonna be too bad for nobody
except for my brain
oh hello well this isn't the worst thing
I've seen today I mean I saw a waterfall
of blood shooting up to the ceiling that
was pretty interesting yeah
alrighty then this mean oh no
oh should I run is it bad as I should
run oh okay
Oh still behind me isn't it what is it
what is it oh it's amaze oh why do I
gotta be going through I got Deb [ __ ]
you oh god okay alright I didn't catch
what it was but it looked bad it's my
understanding that that thing wants to
murder my face off our god damn it Oh
God [ __ ] you oh god damn it oh [ __ ] this
thing oh there's not okay is it fast is
it slow how fast is it can it just go
through the walls
that's [ __ ] me I think it's pops in
existence Oh nope it does
it's like a weird goat eyeball monster
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah oh god damn it yeah
[ __ ] you I'm dead I'm dead I'm so dead
last I don't feel like I'm in the
hospital anymore I have no idea where I
am oh hey oh come on
oh that's the entrance isn't it that's
the entrance isn't it I think every time
I turn around oh never mind it's just
Dom dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead yep
I'm dead okay well okay let's try that
again
how am I supposed to solve a maze on my
first try I got completely turned around
in the beginning of the game or
beginning of the maze shut up
here we go alright Mays Mays Mays Mays
Mays Mays Mays Hughes don't pull a maze
Hughes on me okay I think I've gone this
way before and I got trapped before
dammit
hahaha yes yes yes I did it I did it
okay I'm so sorry my little angel I
tried hating the man that took you from
us but in the end the only person I can
hate is myself you always like to scare
people especially when they didn't
understand something
I was confounded no one understood your
costume but I guess people don't read
Poe anymore even with the new price film
that man clearly overreacted to your
fireworks but we can only blame a PTSD
sufferers so much oh oh
oh they're talking about spooky maybe oh
okay good I don't have to go through the
maze again well that's comforting
okay so okay so that's comforting so now
I can get to the exit door but I have a
funny feeling it's not gonna be that
simple because what about the endless
hallway in the basement okay so the exit
door that they were talking about is
this over here
great can't be the end can't be that
easy
oh hey how's it going yep hello
I would imagine okay maybe we will yeah
okay oh how are you feeling
Oh yep yep yep this seemed good seems
good aims good very comforting very
comforting yep yep
what oh no way
those into the deal see what are they
talking about
what a load of bull one load of all
little bull what about the endless
hallway there had to be something else
down there and I gotta look that up hang
on a second
that can't be right well that can't be
your okay hey I got BRB so I read up
that no matter what keep walking down
the hallway oh no what the Bologna new
game+ who new game+ - I don't know a New
Game+ it okay I'll be right back because
this I want to get to this so apparently
some things are different in New Game+
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
goodbye here and then explore New Game+
if there's enough to warrant another
episode of new content that I can find I
will squeeze it all into one big episode
so I'll leave you with that if there's
nothing obviously there won't be another
episode but I'm gonna explore because
I'm very curious I love it when games
piqued my curiosity so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will soon
in the next video hi-yah